we get can we get another look at the
at the game-winning play
from the inbounds pass because you heard
Eric spolster talk about Max struce who
said max did what he was supposed to do
he kept he kept the ball from getting to
Jason Tatum so I just I'd love for you
guys to look at this and then tell me
what what you think about how it was
defense stand here we go
so there's Tatum's out front and there's
this guy who's denying and then
the smart that has nothing to do with
screws that's just a fluke play he did
he no that's what I'm saying yeah that
this is not spruce's fault they got back
there yeah this is just because you know
you cannot Eric Eric said Spruce did
exactly right you're not letting him the
way he's playing
it's just a bad balance and the ball
just came off the only way it could come
off
it just came off perfect so and he
almost blocked it I'm glad Coast postra
said that yeah because because like but
who doesn't know that no some food at
home herself but then blocks him out
yeah if you were sitting at home food
you would have said while there's truth
boxing them out first of all I'm not a
fool second of all I'm the best in the
business and breaking down a table yeah
okay I'm watching him go don't hurt
yourself very humble no because he's
gonna call me a fool okay I gotta go the
other way here
I'm glad it's coacher said that and I'm
glad you showed that